Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. And we would like to go over to Crawford, Texas, where we are joined by a special guest. I'll answer the question. I looked the man in the eye. I found him to be very straightforward and trustworthy. We had a very good dialogue. I was able to get a sense of his soul. He's
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及我们深受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史其余部分》。我们想把视线转向德克萨斯州克劳福德，一位特别嘉宾将与我们连线。我来回答这个问题。我直视了那个人的眼睛。我发现他非常坦率且值得信赖。我们进行了很好的对话。我能够感受到他的灵魂。他是一位
a man deeply committed to his country and the best interests of his country, and I appreciate so very much the frank dialogue. There was no kind of diplomatic chit-chat, trying to throw each other off balance. There was a straightforward dialogue. And that's the beginning of a very constructive relationship. I wouldn't have invited him to my ranch if I didn't trust him. That was my brilliant impression of George W. Bush. It wasn't actually. That really was George Bush.
深深致力于他的国家以及他国家最大利益的人，我非常感激这种坦诚的对话。没有任何那种试图让对方失去平衡的外交客套。我们有了一次直率的对话。这是一段非常建设性关系的开端。如果我不信任他，我是不会邀请他去我的牧场。这就是我那精彩绝伦的小布什模仿秀。其实并不是。那真的是小布什。
That was our first presidential guest. And that was the occasion in 2001 of his first meeting with President Vladimir Putin. In light of the current situation, we thought that it would be interesting to look at some of the historical context. We've already done an episode on the history of Ukraine, but we thought that it would be, you know, I mean, essentially everyone is asking, how did we get here? What is it that's prompted Putin to do what he's doing? You know, what is the background? Is there an explanation for it that can be discovered in history, I suppose, and in his, specifically in his biography? This is a field that you are much, much more familiar with than I am, but I guess I lived through it, so a lot of it.
那是我们的第一位总统嘉宾。那是2001年他与弗拉基米尔·普京总统的首次会晤。鉴于当前局势，我们认为探讨一些历史背景会很有趣。我们已经做过一期关于乌克兰历史的节目，但我们觉得，你知道，我的意思是，基本上每个人都在问：我们是怎么走到这一步的？是什么促使普京做出他现在所做的事情？你知道，背景是什么？历史中，或者更具体地说在他的生平中，能找到对此的合理解释吗？这是你比我熟悉得多的领域，但我想我是亲历了那个时代，所以很多事情
Yeah. I think, Tom, there's that apocryphal saying by Napoleon, isn't there, that if you know the world, if you've studied the world when a man was 20, you know how his mind works. And Vladimir Putin, like any Russian of his generation, he was born in 1952, has lived through the most colossal, almost unimaginable political, economic, kind of social changes in the former Soviet Union and Russia.
是的。汤姆，我觉得拿破仑有一句虚构的名言，对吧？大意是如果你了解这个世界，如果你研究过一个人20岁时的世界，你就知道他的思维方式。弗拉基米尔·普京和他的那一代俄罗斯人一样，出生于1952年，经历了前苏联和俄罗斯发生的最为庞大、几乎难以想象的政治、经济以及各种社会变革。
And it's only by understanding what's happened to him and his country, I think, that you can actually get into his, well, attempt to get into his head and to understand why Russia is now as it is. So now it's becoming, you know, it appears to be becoming this pariah state, kind of shut off behind a new iron curtain of sanctions. How on earth has it got here? And that's what we're going to try and investigate. I mean, Dominic, of course, it's been an absolutely convulsive period of change, but there is also always the historians's question, change or continuity. And you could say, and people have been saying, that actually not that much has changed.
只有通过理解他以及他的国家所经历的事情，我认为你才能真正进入他的内心，试图走入他的大脑，去理解为什么俄罗斯现在会变成这个样子。所以现在它正在变成，你知道，它似乎正在变成这样一个边缘化国家，被关在制裁的新铁幕之后。它到底是怎么走到这一步的？这就是我们要去调查的。多米尼克，当然，这是一个经历彻底巨变的时期，但历史学家永远都会问一个问题：是变还是不变。你可以说，而且人们也一直在说，其实并没有发生多大变化。
That the Soviet Union was a political system founded on lies, founded on a profound suspicion of the outside, founded on an emphasis on military prowess over everything else. And you could say that Russia today is showing much the same. Is the air of that. Yeah, I don't. Normally, I'm a great determinist in this podcast, but I don't think that's really true, actually. I think that misses. Obviously, Putin himself is a product of the Soviet system, which we'll go into in a second. But I think when you actually go through the period of change, you see that there were alternative paths that Russia could have taken. And Russia isn't fated to be this sort of violent, you know, nationalistic kind of hellhole that so many people imagine. What happened in the USSR in
即苏联是一个建立在谎言之上的政治体系，建立在对外部世界的深深怀疑之上，建立在强调军事力量高于一切的基础之上。你可以说今天的俄罗斯表现出了非常相似的特征。是那种传承。是的，我不同意。通常在这档播客中我是个坚定的决定论者，但我觉得这其实并非事实，真的。我觉得这忽略了。显然，普京本人就是苏联体制的产物，我们一会儿会详细谈到。但我觉得当你真正经历那个变革时期时，你会发现俄罗斯本可以走上其他替代道路。俄罗斯并不是注定要成为那种充满暴力、民族主义色彩的人间地狱，就像许多人想象的那样。在苏联时期
the 1980s and then in Russia in the 1990s, there were all kinds of contingencies and twists and so on. And there were alternative futures for Russia, as we will see. But just before we go to look at the last decade of the Soviet Union, you talked about the idea that Russia wasn't fated to become what it is now. But that idea of fate, the idea that Russia has a particular destiny, I mean, that is something that is very strong in Russian culture, and actually much older, of course, than communism. Yeah, the sort of Dostoevsky and Tolstoy, well, I mean, they're two different things, aren't they, Dostoevsky and Tolstoy. Well, I mean, there are two different things on there, Dostoevsky and Tolstoy. But the idea of Russia having this almost, as you would say, Tom, this almost kind of sacral destiny. You know, the Third Rome, the home of orthodoxy, kind of on the edge of Europe, half in Europe, half out.
在80年代以及后来的90年代的俄罗斯，存在着各种各样的偶然性和曲折等等。俄罗斯有其替代的未来，正如我们将要看到的。但在我们回顾苏联的最后十年之前，你谈到了俄罗斯并非注定要成为它现在的样子的观点。但命运的概念，即俄罗斯拥有某种特殊天命的概念，我的意思是，这在俄罗斯文化中根深蒂固，而且实际上当然比共产主义古老得多。是的，陀思妥耶夫斯基和托尔斯泰，好吧，我的意思是，这是两码事，对吧，陀思妥耶夫斯基和托尔斯泰。好吧，我的意思是，这是两码事，陀思妥耶夫斯基和托尔斯泰。但俄罗斯拥有这种几乎——正如你所说，汤姆——几乎带有某种神圣天命的概念。你知道，第三罗马，正教的发源地，处于欧洲的边缘，半在欧洲，半在欧洲之外。
I mean, that is very deeply rooted in Russia's sense of itself. The sense of embattlement, a sense a distrust of the outside but also a fascination with it um so yes all those things are are are there but there was a sort of slightly stereotypical way we talk about russia so we always talk about i mean even george bush did it there when he talked about knowing putin's soul yeah the idea of the russians having a soul that you must understand that is incredibly deep and dark. I mean, nobody says that about, you know, Belgium. Yeah, Belgium. Nobody says that about Belgium. Maybe Bart Van Loo, our previous guest would say that. But also, I mean, today, when you apply the word exceptionalism to countries, it's generally a pejorative. So people are very sniffy about the
我的意思是，这在俄罗斯的自我认知中根深蒂固。那种四面楚歌的感觉，一种对外部世界的不信任，但同时也对它充满着迷，嗯，所以是的，所有这些东西都存在，但我们谈论俄罗斯时有一种稍微模式化的方式，所以我们总是谈论——甚至连小布什在谈到了解普京的灵魂时也是这样——嗯，俄罗斯人拥有灵魂的观点，你必须去理解它，这是极其深邃且阴暗的。我的意思是，没有人会那样谈论，你知道，比利时。是的，比利时。没有人那样谈论比利时。也许我们之前的嘉宾巴特·范·卢会那样说。但同时，我的意思是，今天当你把“例外论”这个词用在国家身上时，它通常是一个贬义词。所以人们对
idea that there might be British exceptionalism or French exceptionalism, even though clearly, you know, I mean, they are all very exceptional countries. But in Russia, it seems to be something that is pretty fundamental to the way that not just Russian politicians, but large numbers of people within the country think of Russia. Yes. Would you say that's fair or am I stereotyping that? No, I think it probably is fair. I think that's the way that a lot of Russians
可能存在英国例外论或法国例外论这种想法非常挑剔，尽管显然，你知道，我的意思是，它们都是非常特殊的国家。但在俄罗斯，这似乎是相当基础的东西，不仅是俄罗斯政客，而且该国的大量民众也是这样看待俄罗斯的。是的。你会觉得这样说公平吗，还是我在刻板印象化？不，我觉得这可能挺公平的。我觉得这就是许多俄罗斯人
are told to think about themselves, that they have an exceptional, a unique past and a kind of exceptional destiny. And we do think of Russia typically as having an exceptional character. Outsiders do. And that's all that stuff
被告知应该如何看待他们自己的方式，即他们拥有一个特殊的、独特的过去和一种特殊的天命。我们通常也认为俄罗斯具有一种特殊的性格。外来者是这么看的。所有那些关于
about the Russian soul and about Russians are terribly kind of warm people, but they're also, that the price of human life is lower and all that sort of thing that you hear so often. Yes. So I think there is a kind of exceptionalism, both projected from the outside, but also believed inside. I mean, it was expressed very unsettlingly by Putin, and I may be paraphrasing him here, and this may be dis disinformation but didn't he say something to the effect talking with regard to nuclear weapons that um a world without russia wouldn't be a what you know why
俄罗斯灵魂的论调，关于俄罗斯人极其热情，但同时人类生命的价值也更低，以及你经常听到的诸如此类的种种。是的。所以我觉得存在一种例外论，既有从外部投射的，也有内部坚信的。我的意思是，普京对此的表达非常令人不安，我可能是在意译他的话，这也可能是虚假信息，但他是不是说过类似于在谈到核武器时，嗯，一个没有俄罗斯的世界就不会是一个，你知道，为什么
should the why should the world exist if it exists without russia yes and not only has he said that by the way but um his kind of mouthpieces on russian state television have used exactly the same line so that's yeah a well-worn line actually in the sort of putinist ideology right okay so a bit unsettling yeah coming from people with the largest quantity of nuclear weapons on the face of the planet but um something that as we said can be traced back to the czarist period but obviously gets a particular refinement under communism where what had been the russian empire becomes the Soviet Union. And as the Soviet Union is one of two superpowers and sees itself charged with a historical destiny, it is the midwife of world communism. That has sustained it throughout decades of transformation and upheaval. By the 70s, when Putin is coming of age,
要让世界存在，如果它没有俄罗斯的话？是的，他不仅说过这样的话，顺便说一句，而且他在俄罗斯国家电视台上的那些喉舌也使用了完全相同的台词。所以，是的，这其实是普京主义意识形态中一套老掉牙的台词了。好吧，所以这有点令人不安，是的，出自拥有地球上面积最大核武器库的人之口，但是，正如我们所说，这可以追溯到沙皇时期，但显然在共产主义统治下得到了某种提炼，曾经的俄罗斯帝国变成了苏联。由于苏联是两个超级大国之一，并视自己肩负着历史天命，它是世界共产主义的接生婆。这支撑了它经历数十年的转型和剧变。到了70年代，当普京正值青春年少时，
that sense of purpose and of destiny perhaps is starting to fade. It's the age of Brezhnev, a man with kind of insanely huge eyebrows and a kind of rigor mortis. I mean, they're all kind of basically dead. They are constantly getting colds, but keep them in their beds for five years. They wear nothing but overcoats. they wear things under the overcoats i've never seen any evidence for that um yeah you're right so it's always snowing so what's going on so putin is born in leningrad st petersburg in 1952 and he's from a working class family his parents work in a factory um and he goes to leningrad State University in 1970, I think. And he's there for five years.
那种目标感和天命感或许开始消退。那是勃列日涅夫的时代，一个有着疯狂巨大浓眉和僵尸般状态的人。我的意思是，他们基本上都快死了。他们总是感冒，却能在床上躺五年。他们除了大衣什么都不穿。他们在套头大衣里面穿东西，我从来没见过这方面的证据，嗯，是的，你说得对，所以总是下雪，到底是怎么回事？所以普京于1952年出生在列宁格勒（圣彼得堡），他来自一个工人阶级家庭，父母在工厂工作，他于1970年左右进入列宁格勒国立大学。他在那里呆了五年。
And so he comes of age in the Brezhnev era, as you say. And it's an age of, it is not an age of revolutionary zeal at all. So you mentioned communism and a sort of sense of communist zeal. But that really isn't what typifies the Brezhnev regime. The Brezhnev regime is all about stability, and there's a kind of ordinariness to it. So for most people who are alive in the Soviet Union at that point, the Soviet Union is all they've ever known. And everybody in the world, you know, in America and Britain, in Western Europe and in the Soviet Union, thinks the Soviet Union is going to probably be around forever you
所以他正如你所说，在勃列日涅夫时代长大成人。那是一个时代，它绝对不是一个充满革命热情的时代。所以你提到了共产主义和某种共产主义热情的意识形态。但那并不是勃列日涅夫政权的典型特征。勃列日涅夫政权完全关乎稳定性，其中有一种平凡感。所以对于当时活在苏联的大多数人来说，苏联就是他们所知道的一切。世界上每个人，你知道，在美、英、西欧以及在苏联，都认为苏联大概会永远存在下去
know it is as you say one of the two superpowers um it's sclerotic uh the economy is producing enough to keep people happy so they're fed they've actually got more consumer goods than ever before um you know robert service in his history of russia says i think he uses the phrase most russian workers had never had it so good as they had it in the 1970s. So they've got fridges, they go on holiday there. You know, life's okay. But relatively, relatively, they've never had it. I mean, they've never had it so good.
你知道，正如你所说，它是两个超级大国之一，嗯，它已经僵化了，经济生产的东西足够让人们快乐，所以他们吃饱了，他们实际上拥有了比以往任何时候都多的消费品，你知道，罗伯特·瑟维斯在其所著的俄罗斯史中说，我想他用过这样一句话：大多数俄罗斯工人的日子从来没有像在1970年代那样好过。所以他们有了冰箱，他们去那里度假。你知道，生活还行。但相对而言，相对而言，他们从来没有过上这样的日子。我的意思是，他们的日子从来没有这么好过。
But relative to the capitalist West. Of course, it's falling further. Economically, they're starting to fall behind. And the prosperity, the apparent prosperity of the 70s is based on a fiction. So it's based on a sclerotic, incredibly complicated, top-down sort of system. You know, the sort of parodies of sort of state planning and tractor statistics and all that stuff. They're all rooted in truth. But it's also rooted in high oil prices. So high world, they're almost living a bit of an illusion. Because when the oil price falls in the 1980s,
但相对于资本主义西方而言。当然，它正在进一步落后。在经济上，他们开始落后。而且70年代的繁荣，即表面的繁荣，是建立在虚构的基础之上的。所以它是建立在一个僵化的、极其复杂的、自上而下的体制之上的。你知道，那种对国家计划、拖拉机统计数据等等的种种讽刺。它们都植根于现实。但它也植根于高油价。所以高油价的世界，他们几乎是在靠一种幻觉过日子。因为当1980年代油价下跌时，
that's going to pull the rug out from the system. And Brezhnev, as you say, I mean, he's not Stalin. He's nothing like Stalin. It's still a very autocratic system. It's one that represses dissidents and shoves them into psychiatric hospitals. But it doesn't kill lots of people. So life kind of goes on goes on and for a young man like putin his ambition is to join the kgb um supposedly he applies to join and they say to him
那将抽走这个体制的基石。正如你所说，勃列日涅夫，我的意思是，他不是斯大林。他一点也不像斯大林。这仍然是一个非常专制的体制。这是一个镇压持不同政见者并将他们塞进精神病院的体制。但它不会杀死很多人。所以生活就这么继续下去了，对于像普京这样的年轻人来说，他的野心是加入克格勃。据说他申请加入，而他们对他说，
you don't apply you know we contact you but they kind of make a note of him because they know that he's loyal and hard-working and all this sort of stuff um so for him he thinks he's going to be he thinks he's joining the intelligence service of one of of of the actually the world's great power because the 1970s is a terrible decade for the kind of the united states it's the decade of nixon and carter and vietnam and this sort of introspection and the soviet union there's a sort of sense that the soviet union might even be winning the cold war burying them burying them as yes, as Khrushchev said to Nixon. So there's this sort of false image, I think, that people have about their own society in the 70s.
你不需要申请，你知道，我们会联系你。但他们记下了他的名字，因为他们知道他忠诚、工作努力，诸如此类。所以对他来说，他认为他将要，他认为他正在加入世界上某个伟大超级大国的谍报机构，因为1970年代对美国来说是一个糟糕的十年，那是尼克松、卡特、越南以及这种内省的十年，而苏联则有一种感觉，即苏联甚至可能赢得冷战，埋葬他们，埋葬他们，正如赫鲁晓夫对尼克松所说的那样。所以人们在70年代对他们自己的社会有一种虚假的印象。
And there are some people at the top of the Soviet regime, so in particular the man who's going to succeed Brezhnev, who's a man called Yuri Andropov, who is the head of the KGB, there are some people who know that there are deep problems, that Russia has, I say Russia, the Soviet Union has huge problems with alcoholism, with absenteeism, that its birth rate is struggling, that high rates of corruption, all these kinds of things. But Putin doesn't see this as a young man, I wouldn't have said. Well, two questions. First of all, Putin, is he a committed this as a young man, I wouldn't have said. Well, two questions. First of all, Putin, is he a committed communist as a young man? Or is he a committed nationalist?
在苏联政权最高层有一些人，特别是即将接替勃列日涅夫的那个人，一个叫尤里·安德罗波夫的人，他是克格勃头子，有一些人知道存在着深刻的问题，俄罗斯——我说的是俄罗斯，苏联在酗酒、旷工方面存在巨大问题，其出生率正在苦苦挣扎，高腐败率，所有这些类型的问题。但我不会说普京作为一个年轻人能看到这一点。嗯，两个问题。首先，普京，作为一个年轻人，他是一个坚定的共产主义者吗？还是他是一个坚定的民族主义者？
What's the balance there? If you read sort of his semi-official biography, it says that he reads, you know, he enjoys reading Marxist-Leninist books when he's at school. I mean, I think it's a bit like Christianity, Tom. Is it? It is, in this sense. There's a difference between christianity tom is it you it is in this sense in this sense there's a difference between being a christian in the second century a.d and being a christian in the 16th century when everybody's a christian and you know you're not a radical you're not a rebel you're
其中的平衡点在哪里？如果你读过他那种类传记，上面说他在学校时就喜欢读马克思列宁主义的书籍。我的意思是，我觉得这有点像基督教，汤姆。是吗？确实是这样。区别在于，基督教，汤姆，是吗？确实是这样。在这个意义上，在这个意义上，公元二世纪的基督徒和十六世纪每个人都是基督徒时的基督徒是有区别的，那时人人都是基督徒，你知道，你不是一个激进分子，你不是一个叛逆者，你
not necessarily you might be in the 16th century yeah but you might not be fine you might not you might be a good christian but none of those things you might just be an apparatchik and um i think he's a communist in the sense that he's listened to everything he's been told, and that provides his framework. But I don't think he burns with the zeal of social justice or with revolutionary enthusiasm. Actually, Tom, I think a lot of the people who are running the show don't burn with revolutionary zeal. Okay, that was my other question. But I think before I ask that, let's take a quick break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
不一定是，你可能在十六世纪是，是的，但你可能不是，好吧，你可能不是，你可能只是个官僚，而且，嗯，我觉得他是个共产主义者，在这个意义上，他听信了灌输给他的所有事情，这构成了他的框架。但我并不认为他怀有对社会正义的热情或革命的热情。实际上，汤姆，我觉得很多掌权的人并不怀有革命的热情。好吧，那是我的另一个问题。但我想在我问那个问题之前，先休息一下。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So we're about 15 minutes in, and to be fair, we have barely scratched the surface. So what we're thinking of doing this week is having a slightly different release schedule from usual.
我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。节目已经进行大约15分钟了，平心而论，我们才刚刚触及表面。所以我们这周打算做的是，采用与以往稍微不同的发布时间表。
We're going to release these episodes charting the fall of the Soviet Union, the chaos in Russia in the 1990s, and the rise of Vladimir Putin. We're going to release these over the next three days. So we're going to break them into slightly more digestible and accessible chunks because it's such a complicated and an important subject. Now, we will obviously return to our usual schedule next week. But we had such a big response to our Russia and Ukraine episode and so many requests for us to do these stories as well. We hope you understand. And I have to say, if you cannot wait for the rest of the story if you literally cannot wait till tomorrow morning and why would you be able to wait Tom there's another option for people isn't there
我们将发布这些描绘苏联解体、1990年代俄罗斯混乱以及弗拉基米尔·普京崛起的节目。我们将在接下来的三天内发布这些内容。所以我们将把它们拆分成更容易消化和接受的片段，因为这是一个如此复杂且重要的主题。现在，我们下周显然会恢复我们通常的时间表。但我们对俄罗斯和乌克兰节目的反响如此巨大，并且有这么多人要求我们做这些故事。希望你们能理解。而且我必须说，如果你等不及故事的其余部分，如果你字面意义上等不到明天早上——汤姆，你为什么要等呢——人们还有另一个选择，对吧？
there is indeed Dominic yes you can join the rest is history club and we appreciate that we've gained a lot of new listeners over the last couple of weeks so let's just quickly explain how it works so the rest is history club members get certain benefits like as dominic just said early access to new episodes uh you get ad free listening you get a bonus episode each week where dominic and i review uh your messages review the episodes that we've done feedback to that all that kind of stuff um we do live shows on youtube once a month so what have we done dominic we've done the 60s haven't we we've done assass done assassinations. We did clubs, great clubs of history. All kinds of stuff like that. So stuff that you wouldn't otherwise get to hear. And also you get access to a chat room where, again,
确实如此，多米尼克，是的，你可以加入历史其余部分俱乐部，我们很感激在过去几周里获得了许多新听众，所以让我们快速解释一下它是如何运作的。历史其余部分俱乐部的会员可以获得某些福利，正如多米尼克刚刚所说，可以抢先收听新节目，嗯，你可以获得无广告收听，每周获得一期加更节目，我和多米尼克在其中会回顾你们的留言，回顾我们做过的节目，对反馈做出回应，所有诸如此类的事情。嗯，我们每月在YouTube上做一次直播。所以我们都做过什么，多米尼克？我们做过60年代，对吧？我们做过暗杀。我们做过俱乐部，历史上的伟大俱乐部。各种各样类似的事情。所以那些你平时听不到的内容。而且你还可以进入一个聊天室，同样，
we discuss the episodes, we give out book recommendations, all kinds of stuff like that. And you can sign up for this, the Rest Is History Club at restishistorypod.com. That is restishistorypod.com. It's £6 a month, and you become a friend of the show. Now, just one tiny last bit of self-promotion, for which I apologise. We do also have a gold-level member tier, and they're called the Athol Stans, and they get all the friend of the show benefits. And if you join that, you get an invitation to two genuine, actual real parties, Athos fan parties every year. Dominic actually comes out of his Hobbit hole.
我们会在节目中探讨每集的内容，还会给出书单推荐，诸如此类。你可以在 restishistorypod.com 注册加入“历史之息俱乐部”（The Rest Is History Club）。网址是 restishistorypod.com。每月只需 6 英镑，你就能成为节目的“挚友”。现在，请允许我做最后一点微不足道的自我宣传，对此我深表歉意。我们还有一个黄金级别的会员层级，被称为“阿托尔死忠粉”（Athol Stans），他们可以享受“挚友”的所有福利。如果你加入这个层级，你每年将获得参加两次真正、真诚、货真价实的派对——阿托斯粉丝派对的邀请。多米尼克甚至会走出他的霍比特洞穴。
Amazing sight. I mean, am I not going to just address the party on Zoom? I fear I'm not. So, Tom, we have the first date, which I think is Saturday, the 21st of May. And, of course, I'm tremendously excited about it. Yes, and it's in central London. It's in a pub.
真是壮观的景象。我是说，难道我不打算就在 Zoom 上和大家聚会吗？我恐怕不会。所以，汤姆，我们已经有了第一个日期，我想那是 5 月 21 日，星期六。当然，我对次感到无比兴奋。是的，它在伦敦市中心。在一个酒吧里。
So that's very convenient for me, less convenient for you. My argument to have it at Banbury Station, sadly, was vetoed. But the whole Restless History team will be there. Everybody will be there. All the lads. And we're going to be doing a pub quiz
这对我来说非常方便，对你来说就没那么方便了。我曾提议把它办在班伯里火车站，但很遗憾，这个提议被否决了。不过整个“历史之息”团队都会到场。每个人都会去。所有的伙计们。而且我们还准备举办一场酒吧问答赛
for the Athol Stands as well online. And that is coming up this weekend on the Sunday the 13th and Monday the 14th of March. So we've got to get the questions together, all kinds of stuff like that. We do indeed. We do indeed. So that's restishistorypod.com if you want to join the club and you get all these tremendous benefits.
同样也是为“阿托尔死忠粉”在线上举行。时间就在本周末，3 月 13 日星期日和 3 月 14 日星期一。所以我们得把题目凑齐，诸如此类的。确实如此。确实如此。所以如果你想加入俱乐部并获得所有这些巨大的福利，请访问 restishistorypod.com。
And, of course, crucially, you will get early access to the remainder of the episodes on this story, the fall of the USSR, the creation of Russia, the Russian Federation in the 1990s, and the rise of Putin. And, of course, if you don't want to join all that, and you are absolutely bridling and furious at having the stories been interrupted by this shameless self-promotion, don't worry, you can carry on listening for free, and we will get right back to it right now. Yeah, that is enough shameless self-promotion. Right, Dominic. So you were just saying before the break that a lot of the people at the top of the Soviet Union are not burning with kind
当然，至关重要的是，你将提前收听本系列剩余的剧集：苏联的解体、俄罗斯的诞生、20世纪90年代的俄罗斯联邦以及普京的崛起。当然，如果你不想加入这一切，并且对这些故事被这种无耻的自我宣传所打扰感到愤怒和恼火，别担心，你可以继续免费收听，我们现在就会马上回到正题。是的，无耻的自我宣传就到这里。好了，多米尼克。所以你刚才在休息前说过，苏联高层的许多人并不充满那种
of revolutionary communist zeal. And the question I asked you was on Andropov. He's the guy who notoriously has the cold. It lasts for what, kind of four years, three years or something? I mean, basically, he's incapacitated for the whole period of his term as general secretary yes and then he succeeded by chinenko who is kind of in many ways even more moribund are these are these guys people who apps you know so andropov is a very smart guy he recognizes the soviet union has huge problems is he a believer though he doesn't question the system he just thinks that the system needs a bit of tinkering you know apply the spanner here a bit of oil there and it will tick along fine uh he doesn't question the mission i suppose is what i would say um so i mean chanenko he's a hack he's just a party hack andropov is clever he was the soviet ambassador i think in
革命的共产主义热情。我问你的问题是关于安德罗波夫的。他就是那个出了名地一直感冒的人。持续了大约四年、三年还是什么的？我的意思是，基本上，在他担任总书记的整个任期内，他都丧失了工作能力，是的，然后接替他的是契尔年科，他在很多方面可以说是更加垂死。这些人，这些家伙，他们是那种——你知道的，所以安德罗波夫是个非常聪明的人，他认识到苏联有巨大的问题。但他是个信仰者吗？他不质疑这个体制，他只是认为这个体制需要一点小修小补，你知道的，在这里用个扳手，在那里加点油，它就能正常运转了。嗯，他没有质疑这个使命，我想这就是我会说的。嗯，所以契尔年科，他是个庸官，他只是个政党庸官。安德罗波夫很聪明，我想他曾担任苏联驻
hungary during the budapest uprising so he he has taken from that a belief that you have to be you have to be strong. You have to suppress dissent. You can't let things – but he also has taken a belief that you have to get in ahead. So you can't let yourself get in a situation where thousands of people are in the streets. You have to keep changing the system to make it work. So I don't think Andropov is – he's very severe. He's very strict.
匈牙利大使，正值布达佩斯事件期间。所以他从中得出的一种信念是，你必须强硬。你必须镇压异见。你不能让事情——但他也得出了一种信念，那就是你必须防患于未然。所以你不能让自己陷入成千上万的人走上街头的境地。你必须不断改变体制以使其运转。所以我不认为安德罗波夫是——他非常严厉。他非常严格。
He's very anti-corruption. And he's clever. And he has read forbidden books. And as Soviets, sort of the top brass are allowed to do, they're expected to do, to inform themselves. And he's surrounded himself with aides who are relatively free thinking. But he's still, I mean, everybody there believes in them, that their model must triumph. And they believe they're in a global competition with this, with the United States. Absolutely. Yeah. And so he is, you know, said he was head of the KGB. He's general secretary during the kind of the coldest days of the Cold War in the early 80s. Yes.
他非常反腐。而且他很聪明。他读过禁书。作为苏联的高层核心，他们被允许这样做，被期望这样做，以此来了解情况。而且他身边环绕着相对思想自由的助手。但他仍然——我的意思是，那里的每个人都坚信他们的模式必然胜利。他们相信自己正在与美国进行一场全球竞争。绝对是的。是的，所以他，你知道的，曾担任克格勃负责人。在80年代初冷战最寒冷的日子里，他是总书记。是的。
So he is the guy who's in charge when Reagan is lambasting the Soviet Union as evil. Yeah. And it's 99 red balloons and two tribes, which is very frightening, by the way, for the Soviet leadership. They, they think the Americans are going to attack them.
所以当里根猛烈抨击苏联为邪恶帝国时，他就是那个掌权的人。是的。还有《99个红气球》和《两个部落》，顺便说一句，这让苏联领导层感到非常恐慌。他们认为美国人要进攻他们。
Well, I mean, we did a podcast about this with Taylor Downing about nuclear war. They absolutely are terrified that the Americans are going to attack them first. But yeah, so Andropov takes over Brezhnev dies. I mean,
好吧，我的意思是，我们曾与泰勒·唐宁一起就核战争做过一期播客。他们绝对 terrified（吓坏了），生怕美国人会首先攻击他们。但是，是的，所以安德罗波夫接权，勃列日涅夫去世。我的意思是，
Brezhnev basically died multiple times and was literally brought back from the dead. You know know he's sort of resuscitated and dragged around as this sort of embalmed figure in the late 1970s Andropov succeeds in November 82 and is there till February 84 and as you said he's basically ill the whole time I mean they literally you know on one side of his bed there'll be the man with the nuclear briefcase the other side of his bed will be the nurse who's keeping him alive um and then he dies now the person he wants to succeed him is the crucial figure in this podcast and for putin a figure of of utter ignominy and shame in russian history as indeed he is for a lot of russians and that man is mikhail gorbachev that's the man that andropov wants to take over but he doesn't he's too young so the other people in the Politburo, they bypass him
勃列日涅夫基本上死过好几次，而且字面意义上是从死里复活。你知道的，他在 20 世纪 70 年代末被某种程度上复苏并拖来拖去，就像这样一个防腐木乃伊一样。安德罗波夫在 82 年 11 月继任，一直在任到 84 年 2 月。正如你所说，他基本上整个时期都在生病。我的意思是，他们字面意义上，你知道的，他床的一边会有拿着核公文包的人，他床的另一边会是维持他生命的护士。嗯，然后他死了。现在，他希望接替他的人是这期播客中的关键人物，对于普京来说，这是俄罗斯历史上一个完全耻辱和丢脸的人物，对于许多俄罗斯人来说确实也是如此，那个人就是米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫。这就是安德罗波夫希望接管的人，但他没有接管，他太年轻了。所以政治局里的其他人绕过了他，
and they get this old hack, Chanenko, who is another sort of – I mean, he's dying when he takes over. And he's there from February 1984 to the spring of 1985. So what was it about Gorbachev that Andropov had seen? That's a really good question. So Gorbachev is a generation younger. He's the youngest guy, I think, pretty much on the Politburo. He joins in 1980 and he's 49, which is incredibly young by the standards of the Soviet leadership.
让他们得到了这个老庸官契尔年科，他又是那种——我的意思是，他接任时就已经快死了。他从 1984 年 2 月一直任职到 1985 年春。那么，安德罗波夫在戈尔巴乔夫身上看到了什么呢？这真是个好问题。所以戈尔巴乔夫比他们年轻一代。我想他几乎是政治局里最年轻的人。他于 1980 年加入，当时他 49 岁，按苏联领导层的标准来看，这简直年轻得不可思议。
He has a glamorous wife. He does, right? He's a very clever wife who's a very important, I mean, hugely important figure for him, his chief advisor. I mean, his real soulmate. So Gorbachev is from a place called stavropol he's from a little village called what's it called privol noia i think it's called um and he's from peasant stock he's bright he's he's super bright he's gone to moscow state university and i think he's read law he's got a birthmark on his uh on his head he does he's traveled so he's been abroad he even went got a birthmark on his forehead. On his head, he does indeed. He's travelled, so he's been abroad.
他有一个光鲜亮丽的妻子。他确实有，对吧？他有一个非常聪明的妻子，她是一个非常重要的人，我的意思是，对他是极其重要的人物，他的首席顾问。我的意思是，他真正的灵魂伴侣。所以戈尔巴乔夫来自一个叫斯塔夫罗波尔的地方，他来自一个叫什么名字的小村庄？普里沃尔诺耶，我想是叫这个名字。嗯，他是农民出身。他很聪明，他超级聪明。他去过莫斯科国立大学，我想他读过法律。他的头上——他的头上有一个胎记。他确实有。他旅行过，所以他去过国外。他甚至在额头上——他的头上确实有一个胎记。他旅行过，所以他去过国外。
He even went on a three-week driving holiday in France with Raisa. And they sort of drove around France and said, God, you know, this place is so much better than the Soviet Union. You know, this is the sort of classic thing that often happens when people are posted to the West. He actually, one of his chief aides, one of his chief advisors is a man called Alexander Yakovlev, who had been ambassador to Canada
他甚至和赖莎一起在法国进行了为期三周的自驾度假。他们开车环游法国并说：“天哪，你知道吗，这个地方比苏联好太多了。”你知道的，这是一种典型的情况，当人们被派往西方时经常发生。他实际上，他的主要助手之一，他的首席顾问之一是一个叫亚历山大·雅科夫列夫的人，他曾任驻加拿大大使，
and basically had exactly the same kind of crisis of confidence. You know, he got to Canada and was like, oh my God, this place is great. But when Gorbachev becomes general secretary, he's still a believer. I mean, just because he's got a nice camembert in France,
基本上经历了完全相同的信心危机。你知道的，他到了加拿大，心想：“哦，天哪，这个地方太棒了。”但是当戈尔巴乔夫成为总书记时，他仍然是一个信仰者。我的意思是，仅仅因为他在法国吃到了美味的卡芒贝尔奶酪，
it doesn't mean that he thinks... Right, absolutely, Tom. Absolutely, he's a believer. He is idealistic. And this is one of the great problems with Gorbachev. Now, Gorb he's got a nice camembert in France, it doesn't mean that he thinks… Right, absolutely, Tom. Absolutely, he's a believer. He is idealistic. And this is one of the great problems with Gorbachev. Now, Gorbachev is a fascinating character because, of course, everybody listening to this, by and large, will think, oh, Gorby, nice guy. You know, Nobel Peace Prize winner, top man. Of course, in Russia, he is regarded with absolute contempt. And I have to say, when you start to dig into the story,
并不意味着他认为……对，绝对是这样，汤姆。绝对的，他是个信仰者。他很理想主义。这也是戈尔巴乔夫的一大问题所在。现在，戈尔——仅仅因为他在法国吃到了美味的卡芒贝尔奶酪，并不意味着他认为……对，绝对是这样，汤姆。绝对的，他是个信仰者。他很理想主义。这也是戈尔巴乔夫的一大问题所在。现在，戈尔巴乔夫是一个迷人的人物，因为当然，听这个节目的每个人，大体上都会想：“哦，戈尔比，好人。你知道的，诺贝尔和平奖得主，顶级人物。”当然，在俄罗斯，他受到绝对的鄙视。我必须说，当你开始深入挖掘这个故事，
and you think about Gorbachev in a slightly more detached way, I mean, we've done a lot of weak and failed leaders on this podcast, although it pains me to say it because he's an admirable man in so many ways. I mean, but when he leaves office, he's only in there for six years. And when he leaves, his country has completely and utterly fallen apart. Now, some people would say that's because the problems are too great. But I think Gorbachev, I think almost all historians actually who really work on this, people like Robert Service or Vladislav Zubok, who wrote a brilliant book called Collapse that came out last year, The Fall of the Soviet Union, they would just say Gorbachev is a complete and utter disaster. Why? He's idealistic, Tom. He's bright. He and Raisa have spent loads of time talking about the future of the Soviet Union. They like
并以一种稍微超然的方式去思考戈尔巴乔夫时，我的意思是，我们在本期播客中讨论过很多软弱和失败的领导者，尽管我说这话让我感到痛苦，因为他在很多方面都是一个令人钦佩的人。我的意思是，但当他离任时，他只在任了六年。当他离开时，他的国家已经彻底、完全地分崩离析了。现在，有些人会说这是因为问题太大了。但我认为戈尔巴乔夫，我想几乎所有真正研究这个课题的历史学家，比如罗伯特·瑟维斯或弗拉迪斯拉夫·祖博克（他去年写了一本名为《崩溃：苏联的解体》的精彩书籍），他们只会说戈尔巴乔夫绝对是一个彻底的灾难。为什么？他很理想主义，汤姆。他很聪明。他和赖莎花了很多时间讨论苏联的未来。他们喜欢
talking to other kind of intellectually kind of people. Gorbachev is also very canny. So he's been able to get up the kind of greasy pole. He's powerful patrons like Andropov think a lot of him. He says to Raisa when he joins the, he says to race when he joins the i think it's when he joined the politburo he said um we can't live like this any longer and he's determined to fix the system but he goes about fixing it in such a politically incompetent i mean again it slightly pains me to say it um but he he fixes it in such an inept way that absolutely everything gets worse he does too much too quickly too many different areas and everything falls apart and you said what is he a believer he's absolutely a believer so vladislav zubat brings this out really well
与其他那种有知识分子倾向的人交谈。戈尔巴乔夫也很精明。所以他能够在这个充满竞争的官僚体制中爬上去。像安德罗波夫这样有权势的赞助人非常看重他。他在加入——我想是加入政治局时对赖莎说：“我们不能再这样生活下去了。”他决心修复这个体制，但他修复它的方式在政治上是如此无能——我的意思是，再次声明，说这话让我有点痛苦——但他以如此拙劣的方式去修复它，以至于绝对所有事情都变得更糟了。他做得太多、太快、涉及太多不同的领域，一切都分崩离析了。你刚才问他是不是一个信仰者？他绝对是一个信仰者。所以弗拉迪斯拉夫·祖博克在书里很好地阐述了这一点
in his book he says you know gorbachev is obsessed with lenin i mean this is so much like that you're parallel with your christianity stuff about, you know, people who would kind of, Oliver Cromwell or somebody, reading the Bible to guide them. Gorbachev has Lenin's sort of works on his desk, and he will sort of dip into them in the way that people sometimes dip into the Bible. He will dip into them to try and get inspiration for what he needs to do. And he becomes convinced, he is convinced that the Soviet Union has taken a wrong turn since the 1920s. And it needs to get back to Lenin's vision. He idealizes Lenin, and he thinks Lenin had a vision, it's a more democratic, free, open, creative. And if I can get back to that, we'll establish true communism. And then we'll turn
在书中，他说：“你知道的，戈尔巴乔夫痴迷于列宁。我的意思是，这太像了，你把这与你关于基督教的东西进行平行对比，比如奥利弗·克伦威尔或某人通过读圣经来指导自己。”戈尔巴乔夫的桌上放着列宁的著作，他会像人们有时翻阅圣经那样去翻阅它们。他会翻阅它们，试图为他需要做的事情寻找灵感。他变得确信，他深信苏联自 20 世纪 20 年代以来走错了路。它需要回到列宁的愿景。他将列宁理想化，他认为列宁有一种愿景，那是更加民主、自由、开放、有创造力的。如果我能回到那个状态，我们就能建立真正的共产主义。然后我们将
this sort of sinking ship around, if you can turn the sinking ship around so that's that's quite a kind of abstract sense of mission but i maybe i've got this wrong but i thought that he was also focused on a very specific problem which was that uh the soviet economy was massively distorted by defense spending so yeah they they're spending what 20 25 percent no it's probably not that's actually been exaggerated about 15 i think is the latest estimate quite a lot it is but it's if he's going to if they're going to you know guns to butter yeah then they need to make things up with the west so he does that very effectively i mean he's very good at that yes he he definitely kind of removes the chill from the cold war very effectively, which is why people in the West rate him so highly.
扭转这艘正在下沉的船，如果你能把这艘下沉的船扭转过来的话——所以这是一种相当抽象的使命感。不过，也许我弄错了，但我原以为他还专注于一个非常具体的问题，那就是苏联经济被国防开支严重扭曲了。所以，是的，他们把多少钱——20%，25%？不，可能没有那么多，实际上被夸大了，最新的估计大约是15%左右，相当多。确实如此，但如果他要——如果他们要实现“大炮换黄油”，那么他们就需要与西方修好。所以他非常有效地做到了这一点——我的意思是，他在那方面非常擅长。是的，他非常有效地消除了冷战的寒意，这就是为什么西方人对他的评价如此之高。
But as someone who is ideologically committed to Marxist-Leninism, I mean, isn't it a definition of the job that kind of trying to construct an economy that will provide Soviet citizens with all the kind of consumer durables and gizmos that you get in the west is bound to fail i mean it's there's just no way it can be done no i don't agree with that i don't actually don't agree with either of those things so first of all the defense spending um that has become a very comforting myth that the west tells itself about the soviet union that particularly in america that we crippled we won the cold war by increasing defense spending so much that they couldn't keep up. But most historians, I think, would now say they could keep up. I mean, they have- With defense spending.
但作为一个在意识形态上忠于马克思列宁主义的人，我的意思是，试图构建一个能够为苏联公民提供在西方能买到的所有耐用消费品和小玩意的经济体，这难道不是注定要失败吗？我的意思是，根本没有办法做到这一点。不，我不同意这一点。事实上，这两点我都不赞同。首先，关于国防开支，这已经变成了一个非常令人宽慰的神话，西方以此来安慰自己，特别是在美国，我们通过大幅增加国防开支以至于他们无法跟上，从而赢得了冷战。但我想大多数历史学家现在都会说，他们是能够跟上的。我的意思是，他们有——通过国防开支。
Yeah. They've done it since the 40s. They could have carried on doing it. I mean, that defense spending is not what brings the Soviet Union down. Second point, I forgot what your second point was, Tom. Oh, consumer durables. Well, there is a very good example of a communist country that has embraced a consumerism. China. That's China. And the Chinese, I mean, Deng Xiaoping supposedly said something to the effect that his son asked him what he thought of Gorbachev,
是的。他们从 40 年代就开始这么做了。他们本可以继续下去。我的意思是，国防开支并不是导致苏联垮台的原因。第二点，我忘了你的第二点是什么了，汤姆。哦，耐用消费品。好吧，有一个很好的例子证明一个共产主义国家已经拥抱了消费主义。那就是中国。那是中国。而且中国人——我的意思是邓小平据说曾说过这样的话，大意是他的儿子问他对戈尔巴乔夫有什么看法，
and he said, I think Gorbachev's a complete idiot. Yes, but this is communism with Chinese characteristics, which basically means a kind of freedom to ignore aspects of communism that don't gel with with making money but but leninism absolutely i mean leninism is all about kind of collectivization but it's all about suppression of private enterprise but i think most historians would say well first of all that's not what gorbachev himself thinks he thinks lenin's new economic policy in the 1920s after the russian civil war did allow some space for limited private enterprise and that they can move towards a mixed economy.
他说：“我认为戈尔巴乔夫是个十足的笨蛋。”是的，但这具有中国特色的共产主义，这基本上意味着一种自由，可以忽略那些与赚钱不合拍的共产主义方面。但是列宁主义绝对——我的意思是，列宁主义完全是关于集体化的，它完全是关于镇压私人企业的。但我认为大多数历史学家会说，首先，这并不是戈尔巴乔夫自己的想法。他认为列宁在 20 世纪 20 年代俄国内战后实施的新经济政策确实为有限的私营企业留出了一些空间，并且他们可以朝着混合经济发展。
I think one of the big problems with the Soviet Union is it's become so reliant on imports paid for with oil revenue. And it's completely failed to develop its own kind of consumer industries. So it's like Saudi Arabia with snow. A bit. What do they do? Do they spend their all money on snow no but i mean it's the sound you know notoriously um economies that have lots of oil yeah to be dysfunctional well yes iran is a good example from the 70s we talked about iran a lot in previous podcasts um and i think yes it's incredibly dysfunctional i mean it's unbelievably complicated economy
我认为苏联的一大问题在于它变得过于依赖用石油收入支付的进口。而且它完全未能发展自己的消费产业。所以它就像是一个有雪的沙特阿拉伯。有点像。它们是做什么的？它们把所有的钱都花在雪上了吗？不，但我的意思是，这是众所周知的，拥有大量石油的经济体往往是功能失调的。嗯，是的，70年代的伊朗就是一个很好的例子，我们在之前的播客中经常讨论伊朗。而且我认为，是的，它极其功能失调。我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信复杂的经济体。
no one I mean when Gorbachev is given that they're talking about this thing called the law of state enterprise which is going to be this law that's going to allow a little bit of more freedom for factories to keep their money and to invest it and that sort of thing Gorbachev says at one point you know I basically don't understand this and nobody really understands well i i feel sympathy i mean basically he's trying to he's trying to mend a machine for which there is no instruction manual i think there's a there's a degree of that um but i think he's also you see the thing is he's trying to mend this machine which has incredibly complicated kind of supply chain networks and and it has this weird cashless system that enterprises use with each other whereas citizens use cash and you can't change one to the other i mean it's
没有谁，我的意思是，当戈尔巴乔夫被赋予权力时，他们正在谈论这个叫做“国营企业法”的东西，这将是一项允许工厂有稍微多一点自由来保留自己的资金并进行投资之类的法律，戈尔巴乔夫在某个时候说，你知道，我基本上不理解这个，也没有人真正理解。嗯，我，我感到同情，我的意思是，基本上他是在试图，他是在试图修复一台没有使用说明书的机器。我想这有，这在一定程度上是这样的，嗯，但我也觉得，你看，问题在于他试图修复这台机器，它拥有极其复杂的供应链网络，而且它还有这种奇怪的无现金系统，企业之间用这个，而公民使用现金，你不能把一种变成另一种，我的意思是，这
completely mad but that's the way it's a bit like any massive sclerotic institution once you start to fiddle with it it becomes very difficult to stop it from falling apart but the other thing is he combines this with a pit so he has the perestroika which is restructuring which kind of has political and economic developments but he combines it with glasnost which is openness and that's in the wake of chernobyl so chernobyl the explosion at chernobyl is in april 1986 and after that gorbachev thinks well i need to i need to increase the speed we need to have more newspapers we need to have more discussion and why is it why does chernobyl have that effect on him because I think he's he's shocked by the incompetence um by the cover-ups by the ineptitude of the managers by the way the atomic industry has been run by their lies
完全是疯狂的，但这就是现状。这有点像任何庞大而僵化的机构，一旦你开始摆弄它，就很难阻止它土崩瓦解。但另一件事是，他把这个与一个，所以他有“经济体制改革”（Perestroika），也就是重组，这在某种程度上带来了政治和经济的发展，但他把这与“公开性”（Glasnost），也就是开放结合起来，而那是在切尔诺贝利事件之后。所以切尔诺贝利，切尔诺贝利的爆炸发生在1986年4月，在那之后，戈尔巴乔夫心想，嗯，我需要，我需要加快速度，我们需要有更多的报纸，我们需要有更多的讨论。为什么会这样，为什么切尔诺贝利对产生这种影响？因为我认为他，他被无能震惊了，嗯，被掩盖行为震惊了，被管理人员的愚蠢震惊了，被原子能工业的运营方式以及他们的谎言震惊了
all of that kind of stuff you know Gorbachev of course he's complicit in covering it up a bit because he's the general secretary and he kind of feels like he has to but he still thinks okay we need to you know we just need to be more open and we need to be more creative crucially one of the things he does now one of the things we haven't talked about at all which is very important for understanding Putin is the Soviet Union and I know we have a lot of very, to us, young listeners, the Soviet Union is not anything like a nation state, and it doesn't even really see itself as an empire. So it's got 15 republics going all the way from Estonia.
所有这些类型的事情。你知道，戈尔巴乔夫当然，他也在一定程度上参与了掩盖，因为他是总书记，他觉得他必须这么做，但他仍然认为，好吧，我们只需要，你知道，我们只需要更加开放，我们需要更具创造力。至关重要的是，他现在做的一件事，我们完全没有谈过的一件事，这对于理解普京非常重要，那就是苏联。我知道我们有很多对我们来说非常年轻的听众，苏联根本不像一个民族国家，它甚至不认为自己是一个帝国。所以它有15个加盟共和国，一直延伸到爱沙尼亚。
I mean, it's a mad state in many ways. It's existed one form or another since the 20s, but it's going all the way from Estonia to kind of Tajikistan. And the Russians are about, roughly about 50% of that, you know, the Russian population. And there's always been the issue of nationalism. You know, there's always been tensions in the Caucasus, in Central Asia, in the Baltics, and so on. And Gorbachev has this idea that by basically devolving a lot of power to the republics, I mean, devolution, Tom, what could possibly go wrong? Devolving power to the republics, that will invigorate the system.
我的意思是，从很多方面来说，这是一个疯狂的国家。它以这样或那样的形式自20年代以来一直存在，但它从爱沙尼亚一直延伸到某种塔吉克斯坦。俄罗斯人大约占其中的50%，你知道，俄罗斯人口。而且一直存在民族主义问题。你知道，在高加索地区、中亚、波罗的海等地一直存在紧张局势。戈尔巴乔夫有一个想法，即通过基本上将大量权力下放给共和国，我的意思是，权力下放，汤姆，能出什么问题呢？将权力下放给共和国，这将为系统注入活力。
But at the same time, he wants to open everything up so people can debate things more freely. So that will obviously give nationalism more room to flourish. But he also combines that with an attack on what he sees as the corruption of the old elites so the old elites are embattled people are talking about new ideas but they're also being given more power the whole thing it's a sort of he creates unwittingly a kind of breeding ground for all these kind of nationalistic movements to thrive. And you see it as early as 1986. You see it in Kazakhstan and in the Baltics and Ukraine, movements calling for new language rights and opposing power stations and all these kinds of things. So the seeds of trouble are there
但与此同时，他希望把一切都开放，以便人们能够更自由地辩论事情。所以这显然会给民族主义更多的繁荣空间。但他也将此与对旧精英腐败的攻击结合起来，所以旧精英陷入困境，人们在谈论新想法，但他们也被赋予了更多的权力，整件事，这是一个，他无意中为所有这些民族主义运动的蓬勃发展创造了一种温床。你早在1986年就能看到这一点。你在哈萨克斯坦、波罗的海和乌克兰都能看到这一点，各种运动呼吁获得新的语言权利，反对发电站以及所有这些类型的事情。所以麻烦的种子已经种下
even after he's only been there a year. And Dominic, do we know what Putin is doing? Yes, we do. So this isn't St. Petersburg still? No. This is the interesting thing. He's not. So around about the point where Chernenko gave way to Gorbachev, Gorbachev came into power. Vladimir Putin has been working for the KGB since the late 70s. And he has now been posted to Dresden, East Germany. Of course he has. Yes, of course.
甚至在他上台仅仅一年之后。多米尼克，我们知道普京在做什么吗？是的，我们知道。所以这还不是在圣彼得堡吗？不是。这就是有趣的地方。他不在。所以大约在切尔年科将权力移交给戈尔巴乔夫、戈尔巴乔夫上台的时候，弗拉基米尔·普京自70年代末以来一直在克格勃工作。他现在被派往了东德德累斯顿。他当然去了。是的，当然。
So what he's doing, and he's doing sort of slightly, it seems there are different stories. Some people say he's just compiling information about dissidents. Some people say, actually, he's trying to sort of forge links with the sort of remnants of the Red Army faction, the Baader-Meinhof gang in West Germany. We don't know because, of course, it's secret. But what we know is he's watching all this from outside. So he has left a state that he thinks is powerful, strong, respected in the world, high status. And he sees this guy trying to reform it, to change things. And that's really important, I think, that Putin is watching it from outside. And he's watching it, frankly, with horror.
所以他在做什么，他在做某种程度上，似乎有不同的说法。有些人说他只是在收集关于异见人士的信息。有些人说，实际上，他正试图与西德红军派（巴德-迈因霍夫帮）的残余势力建立某种联系。我们不知道，因为当然这是机密的。但我们知道的是，他正在从外部观察这一切。所以他离开了一个他认为在世界上强大、有力、受人尊重、地位崇高的国家。他看到这个人试图改革它，改变事物。我认为这真的很重要，普京是从外部观察这一切的。而且坦率地说，他是带着恐惧在观察这一切。
And he's in East Germany, which has a higher standard of living relative to the Soviet Union. It does indeed, yes. So he is alert to presumably some of the problems that the Soviet economy faces yes I don't think you asked if Putin was a communist um he's certainly not a communist now and has not been since the fall of the USSR but what he is is a believer in the Russian world in the Russian sphere of influence and I think that's what's going to trouble him as we get into the late 80s and early 90s, that that starts to fragment and fall apart. Well, I think that's enough for today. So that's the end of today's episode. Please join us tomorrow
他在东德，相对于苏联来说，东德的生活水平更高。确实如此，是的。所以他很可能注意到了苏联经济面临的一些问题。是的，我不认为你问过普京是否是共产主义者，嗯，他现在肯定不是共产主义者，自苏联解体以来就不是了，但他是一个相信俄罗斯世界、俄罗斯势力范围的人。我认为这就是在80年代末和90年代初开始让我们感到困扰的事情，即它开始碎片化和瓦解。好吧，我想今天就到这里。今天的节目就到这里。请明天加入我们
to hear about when things really start imploding for Gorbachev in the late 80s and in due course for the Soviet Union itself. We will see you tomorrow. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
听听80年代末戈尔巴乔夫以及随后苏联本身开始真正崩溃时的故事。我们明天见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。